this is a song for miss hedy lamarr
erased by the same world that made her a
star
johnny depp is officially releasing new
music with jeff beck johnny and jeff are
collaborating on a new album titled 18.
it feels great
it's his first major move since winning
his defamation trial against his ex-wife
amber heard
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
the announcement came on johnny's 59th
birthday a little gift for the actors
fans as part of the big news jeff says
he was blown away by their lead single
called this is a song from miss heaty
lamarr when johnny asked him to play on
it it was also one of the main reasons
jeff approached johnny to make an
[Music]
album painless this songs for you
turns out johnny respects jeff's musical
talents too depp called it an honor to
play and write music with jeff he even
went on to call him one of the true
greats and even his brother
talk about brotherly love now this isn't
the first time the pair has joined
forces
[Music]
johnny played multiple shows with jeff
in the weeks leading up to the final
verdict of his defamation case i mean
when i was a kid all i dreamed about was
becoming a famous rock star or you know
this i don't know
this great musician depp's first public
appearance after winning the trial was
giving a surprise performance at jeff's
uk show he was also caught partying with
jeff and tom jones in london when the
jury announced the winning verdict
sharon osborne and johnny's ex kate moss
even attended the concert showing their
support kate took to the stand in the
trial testifying on johnny's behalf did
mr depp push you in any way down the
stairs
none after his big win a source told e.t
johnny's looking forward to his future
saying quote he feels like things are on
the upswing for him and like he's
cleared his name he's looking forward to
the future both personally and
professionally and feels like he got his
career back and so far looks like
johnny's leaning into his creative side
[Music]
depp's lawyers also made it clear on gma
that the actor just wants a return to
normalcy we obviously can't disclose
attorney-client communications but as mr
depp testified and as we both made clear
in our respective closings this was
never about money for for mr deb
so this was about restoring his
reputation and he's done that
[Music]